sky news understands that bidders for
chelsea fc have been given
extra time to submit offers following
the british government decision to
sanction roman abramovich all this
following another turbulent day at
stamford bridge reports that the club
had several of its bank accounts
temporarily suspended our sports
presenter jackie bill trout is here to
to take us through exactly what is going
on at the moment and because the simple
truth of the matter is as far as i
understand it chelsea are incredibly
limited in what they can do
until the sale goes through yeah
absolutely it's almost like they've been
have had handcuffs put on them i mean
they've got this huge wage bill which is
28 million pounds a month which they've
got to they've got to meet that wage
bill i've been they've been told their
players will be paid but they can't sell
any ticket so you can't get revenue from
that they can receive money from tv
companies so they can receive their
premier league money and their champions
league money but they're not allowed to
use that to pay the players you can't
even sell match day programs they've
made match day programs for tomorrow but
they can't employ any sellers to sell
them so not that brings in that much
money but you know everything is
affected i'm not even sure if you'll be
able to buy a pie
there tomorrow i mean we'll we'll know
soon enough but you know very much
hamstrung um i think this sale needs to
go through quickly um willow by the
getting it for a bargain price
possibly um abramovich put a 3 billion
pound price tag on this uh club and now
we're talking around just over two
billion uh for offers but um i think
they'll also have to get a special
permit from the government to make this
sale go through but the players must be
worried you know you've got players out
of contract at the end of the season
whose negotiations would be happening
about now um people like azpilicueta for
example out of contract so what what do
those players do do they just assume
they're not going to get a new one and
move on what about young players who
might have had improved contracts done
like mason mount for example did they
move on and get their worth somewhere
else what about the youngsters who've
come through the academy who might have
got a professional contract at the end
of this season and what about the
academy that costs money to run it's
it's an excellent academy um really sort
of set up by abramovic what happens to
that if they've got no money you know
will this club go to the ground um it's
not in the interest of the government to
do that you know it's it's a big part of
uh society it's been there for a very
long time chelsea nobody wants to see to
see it go to graduates
apart from their rivals who might want
to you know want one one of those top
four places that chelsea currently
occupy but you know there's a lot of
uncertainty around at the moment um
even thomas tucker who seems unflappable
is in the state of i have no idea what's
going to happen next
to understand the situation is very
difficult to see like
where it's going where it's heading it's
maybe impossible so
in the end we
we stick to the mantra to to live in the
moment and and worship where we are
it's not easy
but it's out of our control makes things
um
sometimes more difficult but sometimes
also like
maybe easier to accept that we cannot do
anything in the moment and then to wait
and constantly adapt
so the investment bank reign will decide
on the preferred buyer there's several
uh lines up what's going to be
interesting about their match tomorrow
against newcastle at home is the the
fans have been told not to chant roman
abramovich's name which they did when
they meant to be clapping for ukraine
last week and um thomas tuchel there was
not very happy about that at all they've
been told not to chance his name um i
wonder if they will you know because to
a lot of fans he's rescued their club
and they're not going to forget that
very easily no one forgets five premier
league titles or two champions legal
five fa cups they're not going to forget
that overnight yeah i don't think either
of us are wondering whether they're
going to be seeing it but is it tainted
now everything they've won is it now
tainted because of the money used to get
those successes